you find yourself changing you and I are
becoming more mature gentlemen yeah as
we get into our late 30s yeah and so
what are you laughing for it's possible
it is possible yeah no you know I've got
mean I like because I grew up in a
generation where of course hip hop was
new taking them on this you know taking
on so I'm like hip hop
hey this is the Rockefeller hat on rock
right yeah yeah this is rock nation
right now yeah that's all I like rap you
know but you know like now that I'm
getting older you got to turn it down
after ten o'clock like Gucci Mane is but
turn him down what about the fashions
now the phone yeah yeah they're that no
I'm not I mean it started out the skinny
skinny jeans it's gotten too too much
for me yes like did I mean it's one
thing to wear some tight jeans there's
another thing to have to kind of put
your pants on like this yeah there's a
guy that's not acceptable
jeans I've tried yeah yeah I'm sure
I try but you know he's like they both
they just soak they're so skinny they
get caught around my leg and I just end
up looking like a toddler though yeah
I can get a sleeve hand into one skinny
jean yeah I got mud pies are too big
foot skinny jeans that would never work
you know I see the guy he couldn't even
get a skinny jean he just wore them over
his shoulder walking around without him
like you know he's got a widow just in
case
you